voyager en train avec sa voiture si vide
et peut paraître dépassé aujourd'hui en
france elle porte en vogue dans les
années 60 dans donné les inconvénients
de la route c'est extrêmement bénéfique
le 30 au crochet tête alors la solution
idéale pour voyager de nuit rejoindre le
sud de la france
le train auto couchette s'est intégré un
peu plus à la tradition des vacances la
sncf a mis en service sur la ligne paris
biarritz un nouveau train d'automobiles
accompagné qui prend en charge les
véhicules en même temps que les
voyageurs à cette époque le réseau
autoroutier français n'est pas encore
développée résultat les vacanciers
adopte le 30 aux couches est considérée
comme plus pratique plus rapide et
surtout plus sécurisant que la voiture
le soir on arrive on met sa voiture sur
le train on passe une bonne nuit et
lendemain matin on l'a à la gare au
monde est sûre d'arriver qui n'est pas
toujours le cas sur la route
malheureusement nos jours dans les
années 70 le 30 au coucher connaît son
âge d'or de plus en plus de personnes
décident d'opter pour ce mode de
transport
en cause notamment la hausse des
carburants due au choc pétrolier de 1973
et la limitation de vitesse à 90 km
heure sur les routes en 1957 la sncf
avait lancé la première liaison boulogne
lyon le train couchettes avait
transporté 3 mille trois cents véhicules
cette année là en 1973 43 mille
voyageurs ont choisi cette formule est
près de 16000 voitures ont pris trop à
partir du milieu des années 80 le
développement du réseau autoroutier été
géré va entraîner la diminution
progressive des 30 aux couches est alors
que les vacanciers commencent à
délaisser ce mode de transport
d'autres font encore de la résistance le
rapport entre sécurité le repos
bon une fois par an sont aujourd'hui le
service appartient au passé
en 2019 seuls six gars étaient
desservies par l'auto train dont
marseille et paris bercy le nombre de
voitures transportées est ainsi passé de
62 milles en 2016 à 33500 en 2018
[Musique]